let me ask you a question i know you
asked me the questions but i just want
to talk a little bit about the ai and
you said something about trying to uh
put the emotion in it yeah right
um
so do we so are you thinking there's an
algorithm for emotion
yes
but i think emotion isn't something that
there's a
algorithm for for a particular system we
create emotions together so
emotion is something like this
conversation it's like magic we create
together so
um i have i've worked with quite a few
robots i've a very simple version of
that i've had you know roomba vacuum
cleaners they're i've had them make
different sounds and one of them is like
screaming in pain like lightly and just
having them do that when you kick them
or when they run into stuff immediately
i start to feel something right so the
emotion okay so the emotion you're
saying is
impulse back on the human yeah but i'm
asking do you think there's an algorithm
for the emotion to being pulsed from
machine the machine
yeah that that's a really good way to
ask it
um
it's it's difficult because i think
ultimately i only know how to exist in
the human world so it's like it's the
question of if a tree falls in the
forest nobody's there to see it does it
still fall
i i still think that ultimately machines
will have to
show emotion to other humans and that's
when it becomes real i've been thinking
about this a lot too
and uh
i just okay
do you think the emotion is wave
like light is waving or think it's
particle
so emotion is just a small it's like a
shadow of something bigger and i think
that bigger thing is consciousness so
emotion is just a wave or a particle
i haven't i haven't thought about that
i have thought about it whether it's
there's something like um
whether consciousness or emotion is the
law of physics like if it's that
fundamental to you i had a lyric i had a
lyric i don't know i said this
it comes out uh they did this
documentary about the planet and they
gave i wrote a song it's called the
world of confusion
and uh i'll try to paraphrase the lord
but in the world of the confusion where
there's so much illusions we suck the
blood from the planet
now it needs a transfusion and the
redistribution of wealth
of health
and wealth of self
and a deeper understanding about mental
health
the doctor
described the physical solution
the psychiatrist
wants to build a bigger institution
but neither have the solution
or the equation
to make an instrument to measure the
weight
of the hate vibration
what is the weight of
hate
is it heavier than the weight of love
is it heavier
than the weight of lead inside of a slug
with just
10 milligrams that's all it takes to
kill a man but anyways they're not going
from there but damn that's good but the
question you see the question there yeah
yeah yeah yeah and uh be measured yeah
can that be measured i think so i think
so i just don't got the estimate yet
yeah i yeah so we're in the
dark ages of that but i think it could
be measured i think there's something
physical like something that connects us
all this much you know we tend to think
we humans are distinct entities and we
move about this world but i think
there's some deeper connection
and but we're so
listen
science is in the we just had a few
breakthroughs in the past hundred years
from einstein on the theoretical physics
side
we don't know anything about human
psychology we barely know much about
human biology
we're trying to figure it all out
you